to rescue the crew the helicopter had to
come down low so low it was being
sprayed by huge waves crashing on the
vessel but Italian Coast Guard's managed
to lift 12 people to safety after their
cargo ship was blown onto Sardinia's
rocky coastline across Spain Portugal
and France more than a hundred and
eighteen thousand households are without
electricity in Portugal storm surge
flooding has forced the evacuation of
250 people many houses have been left
under water here except for those homes
built higher-up Islanders on Corsica are
being warned to stay away from the
seaside come somewhere crispy - all as
far as rainfall is concerned we are
seeing the end of the crisis with
regards to the wind we are still in a
crisis that could last a dozen or so
hours 15 or so more in Corsica it is
very important to advise the population
not to go to the beaches and the
coastline because it can be potentially
dangerous Galicia on Western Spain's
Atlantic tip is no stranger to storms
but sights like this are still
remarkable a coastal promenade awash
with sea foam whipped up by the pounding
of countless waves and blown ashore by
storm Fabian's full force and nature's
power always fascinates people and some
get as close as they dare it's
unpredictable and is dangerous but it's
impressively beautiful to Rory challon's
al Jazeera